des hôpitaux débordés à new delhi des
crématoriums de fortune pour faire face
à l'afflux de victimes ou encore
d'immenses cimetière creusées à la hâte
ces images apocalyptiques nous viennent
d'inde où la situation sanitaire dans
les grandes villes semble hors de
contrôle
plus d'un million de nouveaux cas ont
été recensés ces trois derniers jours
dans le pays et les hôpitaux n'arrive
plus à endiguer l'afflux de patients je
suis allé dans presque tous les hôpitaux
de ghaziabad tous m'ont dit qu'ils
n'avaient pas d'oxygène
je me suis donc rendu à l'hôpital rajiv
gandhi ou non nisa a chassé même de
l'entrée en disant qu'il n'avait pas
d'oxygène
puis nous sommes arrivés ici et là été
testés pour le courant navires us mais
ils n'ont même pas prescrit des
médicaments pour lui les médecins ont
prévenu que si nous emmenions mon père à
l'hôpital sans oxygène il n'y avait
aucune garantie qu'ils sont sorte on n'a
pas pu trouver d'ambulance du coin on a
dû venir en tout cas il cherchait à
respirer on enlever son masque qui
pleurer en disant sauvez moi s'il vous
plaît mais je n'ai rien pu faire je les
regardais mourir preuve de l'urgence de
la situation
l'armée a été mobilisée pour faire face
à la pénurie de médicaments et surtout
d'oxygène un train a même été
spécialement affectés au transport
d'oxygène pour ravitailler les hôpitaux
de certaines provinces
un déploiement de moyens apparemment
insuffisant face à la violence de cette
deuxième vague de co vide et à la
virulence du variant indien le système
de santé indien sous financés depuis de
nombreuses années n'arrive pas à
encaisser le choc
résultat le nombre de victimes monte en
flèche plus de 2000 chaque jour mais
pour le premier ministre indien
narendra modi qui s'est exprimé mardi un
confinement généralisée n'est toujours
pas à l'ordre du jour
mes amis dans la situation actuelle nous
devons sauver le pays d'un autre
confinement général je voudrais
également demandé aux états de
n'utiliser le confinement qu'en dernier
recours
landes vont essayer de nous protéger
pleinement d'un confinement généralisée
et nous concentrer sur des confinement
localisée nous améliorerons la santé de
notre économie
ainsi que celle de nos compatriotes
optimiste en début d'année sur une
sortie de crise les autorités indiennes
pays aujourd'hui un certain laxisme
malgré la double mutation du virus les
pèlerinages massive sur les lieux sacrés
hindous tels que le festival de coups
mais là non pas été interdite près de 25
millions de pèlerins ont afflué dans le
nord de l'inde
sans réellement respecter les gestes
barrière ces images qui date d'une
dizaine de jours font craindre aux
scientifiques une nouvelle flambée des
cas de contamination